CONFRONTING IRAN IS ALSO
CONFRONTING THE MAIN PARTNER OF
RUSSIA.
>> SO, YOU HAVE MENTIONED HOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS A FRIEND OF
40 YEARS.
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVEN'T ALWAYS
SEEN EYE TO EYE ON A LOT OF
ISSUES.
HE SAYS HE ONCE SIGNED A PHOTO
BIBI I DON'T AGREE WITH A DAMN
THING YOU SAY BUT I LOVE YOU.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WHEN IT COMES TO
NOBODY IS THERE, JUST YOU TWO ON
THE PHONE.
HE'S TELLING YOU WHAT HE NEEDS
FROM YOU.
YOU'RE TELLING HIM WHAT YOU NEED
FROM HIM.
>> EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS.
I MEAN, LOOK, WE'VE BEEN AROUND
THE BLOCK SO MANY TIMES.
WE WERE THE NEW KIDS ON THE
BLOCK WHEN HE CAME IN AS A YOUNG
SENATOR FROM DELAWARE AND I CAME
IN AS A YOUNG ISRAELI DIPLOMAT,
NUMBER TWO IN OUR EMBASSY.
THIS WAS 1982.
SO WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER A LONG
TIME.
THAT'S 40 YEARS.
AND WE SPEAK OPENLY TO ONE
ANOTHER.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
COMMITMENT TO ISRAEL IS REAL.
IT'S NOT JUST WORDS.
IT'S GENUINE, IT COMES FROM THE
HEART.
AND OUR COMMITMENT, MY
COMMITMENT TO THE ALLIANCE WITH
THE UNITED STATES IS REAL.
IT'S GONE THROUGH MANY
PRESIDENTS AND IT DOESN'T -- IT
HAS TO BE BIPARTISAN, I BELIEVE
IN THAT.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T --
WE AGREE ON EVERYTHING.
WE DISAGREED ON A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
WE DISAGREED ON IRAN.
LESS DISAGREEMENT TODAY I HAVE
TO SAY.
WE DISAGREED ON OTHER THINGS.
AND WE AGREED ON MANY THINGS.
WE AGREED THAT ALLIANCE HAS TO
BE UNSHAKABLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MIDDLE EAST
AND LOOK AT THIS PART OF THE
WORLD, AND YOU SAY, WELL, WHERE
DO YOU HAVE A BASTIEN OF COMMON
INTERESTS AND COMMON VALUES?
IT'S ISRAEL.
AND MOST AMERICANS UNDERSTAND
THAT.
OUR INTERESTS ARE SOUND.
ISRAEL REMAINS DEMOCRATIC AND
WILL BE DEMOCRATIC AFTER THESE
DEMOCRATIC REFORMS WILL BE MORE
DEMOCRATIC.
>> IT'S NOT DEMOCRATIC IN THE
WEST BANK, THOUGH.
I THINK THAT'S THE ARGUMENT THAT
THE BIDEN --
>> NO.
I DON'T SAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE
RIGHT NOW MILITARY NEEDS, BUT
I'M SAYING THAT WE CAN FASHION
THEM IN A CIVILIAN AGREEMENT
THAT MAINTAINS ISRAEL'S
OVERRIDING SECURITY.
I DON'T THINK THE PALESTINIANS
ARE THERE.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT OUR
INTERESTS ARE CONVERGING AS
NEVER BEFORE BECAUSE IN THE 21st
CENTURY, THE FUTURE BELONGS TO
THOSE WHO INNOVATE.
ISRAEL IS THE INNOVATION NATION.
THE OTHER INNOVATION NATION.
I THINK THE U.S. IS THE BIG ONE.
ISRAEL IS THE SECOND ONE.
AND WE PROVIDE INVALUABLE INTEL,
INVALUABLE CYBERSECURITY,
WEAPONS DEVELOPMENT AND CIVILIAN
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS CHANGING THE
WORLD.
THAT'S WHY OUR ARAB NEIGHBORS
CAME TO THE ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
BOTH FOR SECURITY BUT ALSO FOR
CIVILIAN TECHNOLOGY WHICH
BETTERS THE LIVES OF THEIR
PEOPLE.
>> ONE THING I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT, ABOUT RUSSIA AND UKRAINE
IS THAT AN ADVISER TO ZELENSKYY
FLOATED YOUR NAME AS SOMEBODY
WHO MIGHT BE A DECENT MEDIATOR
BETWEEN ZELENSKYY AND PUTIN,
BETWEEN UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
I'M WONDERING IF ANYONE IN ANY
POSITION OF POWER HAS EVER
FLOATED THAT IDEA TO YOU?
AND WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
ON IN THE BREAK OUT OF THEEARLY
UKRAINE WAR.
AND I WAS OPPOSITION LEADER AT
THE TIME.
AND I SAID, WELL, I HAVE A
RULE.
ONE PRIME MINISTER AT A TIME.
YOU KNOW, LIKE ONE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME.
>> WHO ASKED YOU TO DO IT?
>> I WAS ASKED.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS OFFICIAL.
IT WAS UNOFFICIAL, SO I DID NOT
EVEN PURSUE IT.
I SAID THERE IS A PRIME
MINISTER, LET HIM, YOU KNOW,
DECIDE WHAT TO DO.
HE TRIED, DIDN'T SUCCEED.
BUT IF --
>> WOULD YOU DO IT NOW?
>> IF I'M ASKED BY BOTH SIDES,
FRANKLY, IF I'M ASKED BY THE
UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE I THINK, YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN'T HAVE TOO MANY COOKS IN
THE KITCHEN.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
OUR OWN BACKYARD TO DEAL WITH.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT THAT I --
I THINK THIS IS OF MONUMENTAL
IMPORTANCE, BECAUSE I THINK A
PIECE OF THE WORLD IS AT STAKE.
AS I THINK THE PIECE OF THE
WORLD IS AT STAKE WITH IRAN
GETTING NUCLEAR WEAPONS, IT
WILL DESTABILIZE THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I'M REALLY
DEVOTING MY EFFORTS TO THAT.
AND THE OTHER PIECE, IDEAS THAT
I HAVE, ECONOMIC IDEAS.
BUT IF ASKED BY ALL RELEVANT
PARTIES, I WILL CERTAINLY
CONSIDER IT.
BUT I'M NOT PUSHING MYSELF, YOU
KNOW.
WHICH, YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
AROUND LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
THERE HAS TO BE BUT A RIGHT
TIME AND THE RIGHT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IF THEY ARISE, I WILL CERTAINLY
CONSIDER.
>> TRUMP HAS ALREADY LAUNCHED A
2024 PRESIDENTIAL BID.
YOU HAVE SAID IF EFFUSIVE
THINGS FOR WHAT HE DID FOR
ISRAEL WHILE HE WAS PRESIDENT.
BUT YOU ALSO CRITICIZED HIM FOR
THE INSURRECTION, THE INSIGHT,
WHICH YOU CALLED, QUOTE, A
DISGRACEFUL ACT WHICH MUST BE
VIGOROUSLY CONDEMN.
AS RECENT SHOCKING WILLINGNESS
TO SIT DOWN AND BREAK BREAD
WITH HOLOCAUST DENIERS AND
VIRULENT ANTISEMITES NICK
FUENTES AND KANYE WEST.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERNS IF
DONALD TRUMP IS BACK IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
DO YOU THINK SNOW FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO LOOK TO A
NEW GENERATION OF LEADERSHIP?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DID PRAISE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BECAUSE HE DID
GREAT THINGS FOR ISRAEL.
HE RECOGNIZE JERUSALEM AS OUR
CAPITAL, KIND OF LATE, BECAUSE
3000 YEARS AGO, KING DAVID
PROCLAIMED IT AS SUCH.
HE MOVED THE AMERICAN EMBASSY
THERE.
HE RECOGNIZED OUR SOVEREIGNTY
IN THE GOLAN HEIGHTS.
HE LED OUT WHAT WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS THE DANGEROUS NUCLEAR DEAL
WITH IRAN.
HE HELPED ME FORGE THE FOREST
ARC PEACE ACCORDS WITH THE ARAB
STATES.
I THINK HE MADE A BIG MISTAKE
ON THIS KANYE WEST THING.
AND I SAID SO.
I'M NOT GOING TO INTERVENE IN
YOUR POLITICS, YOU KNOW THAT.
YOU TRIED, IT'S GOOD THAT